Hilaree: So many things
went awry everyday.
It was a lot of hard work.
And to get to base camp
when I think of all the times
we almost threw in the towel,
it was, a total relief.
Both: Oh, we made it.
Climb on.
We're at what...
like 11,000 feet
we have 7,000 to go.
( audience applause )
So, we made it to
base camp, which...
felt like kind of
a huge accomplishment
in of itself,
was to get to 13000 feet
to get out of the jungle.
We all struggled
so hard individually,
in that jungle.
Everything looked the same.
You know, we're all like pretty
much A-type personalities.
And trying to, you know
rely on people who you
can't communicate with.
Then, finally, you know, we,
we come out above all of this.
And it was like
coming out from, like
being pinned under
water or something.
And all of a sudden
we could breathe.
And we're like "Oh my Gosh,
we're, we're in our environment.
We're where we can, you know
take control of our own destiny.
And we're at base camp."
This was the transition
basically coming out of
the jungle.
For us to come out of the jungle
and see white snow and glaciers
was really an
amazing time in the trip.
But, we'd lost so many
days under town arrest
and we'd lost so many days
trying to find porters that
we were rushed and we were
stressed at this point.
And at no point in those
30 days had we spent
more than two nights
in any one place.
Except for when we were in
Putao under town arrest.
So we were hustling
and we were trying
to switch over all of our gear.
We got to...
high camp, October 30th.
The next day was Halloween.
And I remember this because
I got on the satellite
phone and I called home.
And I remember,
my kids asking me
where their Halloween
costumes were.
Because,
I'd put them in this bin
and I'd forgotten
to tell my husband
and they didn't know where
their Halloween costumes were.
And so I'm like talking
on this phone, like
directing him through the
house to find this bin
to find their
Halloween costumes.
And I was like
"This is so weird."
And then... my older son
you know,
he's seven at the time
and he was having a really
hard time learning to read.
And, he'd been working
on it really hard
so he picked up his book and
read to me over the phone.
And, I mean I'm going to, yeah
like, it was, I was... crushed.
So I had this going on
all at the same time.
That we're trying to turn around
go through all of our gear
that we hadn't seen in weeks.
And we had one day to do it
in, and that was Halloween
and then the next day
we were climbing.
So, we started pulling
out all of our food
and trying to divvy it
up and we realized that
we had actually lost a lot
of food along the way.
We hadn't cut it out as a way of
cutting our bags or
anything like that.
But, we had lost snack bags
and I think some of it
got left in villages.
We'd lost a lot of rice because
there were military outposts
in some of these villages.
And in order for us to
move through that village
they essentially bribed
us out of bags of rice.
So, we were losing some of these
food supplies along the way.
And when we sat down and
sorted it out, we were like
"Okay, we have enough
for eight days of food
to climb this mountain.
And if we really stretch it
out we've got ten days."
But, that's taking
everything with us.
That leaves us basically nothing
for 130 miles walking out
after trying to climb
this mountain.
( instrumental music )
Cory: You know Mark and I
looked and we thought
you know, we should go this way
avoid some of the technicality
of the lower ridge.
And Hilaree thought we
should go another way.
Hilaree: Even just from the get
go trying to pick out camp one
There was... dissension.
( sound of wind howling )
Mark: It turned out that
Hilaree had made the
right call for camp one.
It's just hard making these
decisions so far out there.
( instrumental music )
Renan: Big day.
Going up a giant couloir
with technical climbing
with heavy packs.
( bleep )
Emily:
People were kind of just like,
this is real, it's serious.
But, at the same time
I was just right there
with everyone else.
A lot of the things that I did
today I've never done before.
Cory: Kinda sketchy some
of it too, right?
It was kind of scary.
You are going up 55 degrees,
60 degree ice slope.
( sound of tent flapping )
Whoa!
( instrumental music )
Hilaree: This mountain is
full of surprises.
We have followed yet
another dead end.
So, we have to backtrack an hour
and basically drop elevation.
Then do some steep snow
and ridge climbing.
And then...
And then, I don't know.
In reality, the peak was, like
this Alpine version
of the jungle.
It was up and down.
There was no straight way.
We kept having dead ends, uh...
it was really hard.
I think, as a team we became
really focused on climbing.
But, we sort of lost
that team dynamic.
We stopped focusing
on each other
and how... the team was
gonna get to the summit.
This was our second
day out of base camp.
And we were already in this
crazy Alpine environment.
And that second day we
reached a dead end.
We had to come back
down to camp one.
And then start day
three over again.
And, I think it was
a really kind of...
rude awakening for
all of us that
the mountain wasn't going
to be this sanctuary.
This place... that
we would un-map
and magically arrive
at the summit.
It was going to be
a lot of hard work
and we were very
thin on resources.
Right here,
we're basically standing on
the Tibetan-Burma border.
And... we were just on
our second dead end
coming up from camp two.
And trying to figure
out our route.
The climb was steep.
It was pretty windy, it
was a little bit colder.
I was definitely
missing the down pants
that I'd left,
like at 2,000 feet
in the jungle,
like three weeks earlier.
The big, like 8,000 meter
boots that we didn't bring
and opted for like the
smaller lighter boots.
This is Emily and I on the face.
And so I know that this probably
like, a total news flash.
But, men and women
are different.
Just a little bit.
We have a different
way of communicating.
And...
Emily was definitely my
choice to bring on this trip.
And she was really green in
this kind of environment.
But, I had the
utmost faith in her.
And she's so strong,
but she's emotional
and she was nervous
on a lot of this.
And so, I chose to kind of like
hang back and climb with her.
And on this particular
face I had been in front
and I stopped and I waited
for Cory and Emily to pass.
And I hung back behind
and climbed below her.
And just, hung out with her.
Plus, she's really funny
and she's super fun
and we climb well together.
But I think as we were moving up
towards the summit
that was sort of
perceived as a weakness
with the rest of the team.
And then again, like
women talk about things
a lot more than men.
And when you get
on a big mountain
sometimes the guys just
weren't talking at all.
And Emily and I were like,
"My toes are cold."
Or "How are you layering? Are
you putting that under this?"
And "Are you going to
wear your balaclava
under your hat or
over your hat?"
We were like,
talking about all these things
that like,
girls talk about like, um...
I don't know, like "You put
your hands in your armpits
or down your pants
to keep warm."
And um, I think that was also
like, our kind of chattiness
and like, "Check my harness"
and "How does my anchor look?"
was again sort of this second
tick against both of us.
And...
again was sort of perceived as
like another weakness
as we were moving
up the mountain.
When we got to this face it
was just sort of assumed that
one of the guys was
going to lead the face
and I was like "Wait a second."
Like "I'm... I want to climb.
I want to lead this face."
And it was the first sense
I kind of got where, like
there's a division
going on here.
Where the girls are
in this corner
and the guys are in this corner.
And, in the end
I did lead the face.
And it was fine, and this
led to our high camp
which was at about 18,200 feet.
And we were six days into
the climb at this point.